ACKNOWLEDGING OUR VETERANS WHO
SERVED IN THE ARMY NAVY AIR
FORCE MARINE CORPS THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SERVICE AND WE
CERTAINLY ACKNOWLEDGE YOU AND
OF COURSE- JUST A FEW DAYS AGO
WE HAD MEMORIAL DAY. TO THOSE
WHO THE ULTIMATE SACRIFICE
FAMILIES GOD BLESS YOU ALL. THE
GOOD AFTERNOON LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN RESPONSE TO THE GOAL
BUT NINETEEN EMERGENCY. AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC. SENATORS
AND SENATE STAFF WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE WILL BE HOLDING AND
THE CENTRAL HEARING AND HAS
MADE NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO
NORMAL PRACTICES IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THE PUBLIC CONTINUE TO
HAVE ACCESS. LATER PROCESS
WHILE CONDUCTING THE HEARING IT
IN A WAY THAT PROTECTS THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC
AND OUR EMPLOYEES. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY. IN ANY
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE DESTRUCTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCTOR HEARINGS IN AS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIME IN A FEW TO GO ISSUES
THAT WE WILL. THE LADY OUR
PROCEEDINGS ARE UNDER THE
SEATING SO PLEASE BE PATIENT.
WE LOOK AT YOUR PROCEED. BEFORE
WE BEGIN LET'S ESTABLISH A
QUORUM I'D LIKE TO REMIND
MEMBERS TO TURN ON THE
MICROPHONES SO WHO CAN BE ALL
HEARD SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ARTS LETTER. WHAT I HEAR
GROWTH HERE BROKE HERE THAT'LL-
NIELSEN NIELSEN HERE ROTH-
BREATH HERE NUMBER. WILK
PRESIDENT WILL PRESENT SORRY
HAVE A QUORUM. THE SECRETARY OF
NOTED WE DO HAVE A QUORUM
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN. WE HAVE
ONE BILL ON THE COUNTER TODAY
WHICH IS ON CONSENT. DO WE HAVE
A MOTION ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. SO MOVED WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR WILK. THE
CONSENT CALENDAR HAS BEEN MOVED
BY SENATOR MILK AGAIN PLEASE
TURN ON YOUR MICROPHONE SO
EVERYONE CAN HEAR YOUR VOTE
MADAM SECRETARY. CALL THE ROLL.
SEVEN SB ELEVEN SEVENTY SEVEN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE
RECOMMENDATION TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. ARCHULETA BY LETTER I
GROW. I GROVE I WOULD FOLLOW.
NIELSEN NIELSEN AYE ROTH HI
ROTH AYE NUMBER. WILK HI WELL I.
THE BILL SO WE CAN LEAVE IT
OPEN THE BILL HAS PASSED LASER
JIM THANK YOU. AND AS SHE. HI
N. NUMBER HI FOR THE RECORD.
NUMBER I FROM NUMBER GUY. THANK
YOU LADIES AND GENTLEMEN AND TO
THE STAFF ESPECIALLY FOR THE
WORK YOU'VE DONE THIS MORNING
AND I PUT THIS HERE TOGETHER
AND EVERYONE WHO SUBMITTED
THEIR SUPPORT PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE VETERANS AFFAIRS
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE.
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR CUST YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORD SHOULD. THANK
YOU AND THANK EVERYONE FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND COOPERATION. ISSUE
HERE WE'LL KEEP IT ON OKAY.
WE'RE GOING TO KEEP THE ROLE
OPEN- FOR A FEW MINUTES LATER
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TENANTS.
THANK YOU SIR. ARE YOU ALL
GOING TO. SIR JUST GONNA CALL
HER BECAUSE WE CAN'T START
HOUSING UNTIL SHE CLEARS THIS
ROLE. WELL THEN I CHECKED THE.
WE WILL CONTINUE WITH THE
MEETING AND- FOR THE ROLL CALL
ON THE BILL. WOULD YOU PLEASE
CALL ROLE ONCE AGAIN SB ELEVEN
SEVENTY SEVEN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AND REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE
RECOMMENDATION TO CONSENT
CALENDAR WITH FELLOW I. FELLOW
I GOOD THANK YOU LADIES IN
GERMAN THAT WILL COMPLETE OUR
MEAT ENTER MEETING I WOULD LIKE
TO THANK EVERYONE WHO
PARTICIPATED TODAY THANK YOU
ONCE AGAIN FOR YOUR PATIENCE
COOPERATION WE CONCLUDED THE
AGENDA THIS CAN BE A BETTER FIT
FOR. HIM ADJOURNED THANK YOU.